hey youtubers it's Charlie this week
agents of shield totally took a field
trip to Tahiti temporarily resolved the
sky plot introduced two new characters
from the comic books and left us with a
giant teaser at the end if you're
finding me for the first time usually
Tuesdays are dedicated to Marvel videos
especially if there's a new episode of
agents of shield I also do a Marvel
movie video too so feel free to leave me
any suggestions for future videos and
subscribe to get everything
this week was just a little bit
different just because there were a few
extra trailers to get out but let's talk
some Tahiti so careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet but
number 5 Belinda Mae frees the Beast
Oliver Quinn this is ABC so I didn't
expect her to give him the business too
badly but it was still pretty fun they
hadn't done much with a Quinton
character after they captured him I
would have thought Ward would have been
the first one to smash his face in
though the whole moment was really just
used to get Coulson to figure out that
the clairvoyant wanted Quinn to shoot
Skye so that Coulson would take her to
the Tahiti place and give her whatever
super serum II received plans within
plans this only sucks if you're sky
because shooting her was really a red
herring it had nothing to do with
killing her number four
Bill Paxton guest stars as agent Garrett
from the comic books it's always fun to
see people from the comics Garrett is
mostly known as a former SHIELD agent
who was turned into a cyborg like the
same type of thing that happened to Mike
earlier this season before he became a
SHIELD agent he was guilty of all kinds
of awful stuff had he been in the DC
Universe he probably would have been
recruited for the Suicide Squad that's
how bad he was after the Civil War comic
book line he did get flagged as a
potential new adventure though all I
could think of when he was on-screen
though was the colonial Marines from
aliens which is kind of relevant
actually to one of my other top moments
number three Tahiti
not such a magical place after all so
this is a bit misleading because Tahiti
turned out to be a special facility with
a miracle drug
so it kind of was a magical place I mean
it brought Coulson back to life I'd hope
they would find more comic book teasers
here than they did but a couple of
things we learned were that Nick Fury is
a level 10 agent meaning it probably
stops at ten more to that fact though
WTF does Tahiti stand for it's an
acronym so let's try and solve that
Rubik's Cube in the comments who else
got a real tesseract vibe from the
computer database Fitz and Simmons used
to find that location it's a shield
black site meaning there are probably
more of those hidden illegal underground
bunkers like this all over the world the
Winter Soldier movie is actually gonna
deal with some of these things the
secrets within secrets that Coulson is
dealing with right now
number two the mystery serum that they
gave this guy the whole conceit of this
was is that Coulson discovered it was
the serum that caused him to go crazy
whenever they were bringing him back to
life that's why he didn't want them to
give it this guy if he didn't catch it
though Coulson and the team talked about
how she didn't make any noise whenever
they gave it to her meaning she did not
have the violent reaction like Coulson
did I'll talk about that more in a
second because it's actually a huge deal
and my number one moment
no surprise here blue alien in the
Tahiti room so many WTF thinks about
this so let's start with the biggest
part who is he well right off the top
Marvel does not have legal rights to use
the Kree so the other possibilities are
frost giant or Centurion
yondu from guardians of the galaxy is a
Centauri and that's his race he's played
by Michael Rooker as you can see the
person in the tank looks much bigger
than him meaning I really do think that
it's a frost giant it certainly would
fit with all the other connective Thor
tissue that the show has had this season
so what does it mean that Skye did not
flip out whenever she took frost giant
blood she might have frost giant DNA who
else is there in the Marvel Universe
that looks like a normal human being but
has frost giant DNA mmm-hmm Loki of
course he's a hundred percent frost
giant but he was the runt of the litter
so just because Skye is a potential
frost giant doesn't mean she's related
to Loki but hopefully we'll find out
isn't it just so curious that the next
episode is another Thor based episode
with Lady SIF and Lorelei as Sherlock
would say the universe is rarely so lazy
there's no such thing as coincidences my
Loki clairvoyant theory is starting to
seem a lot less crazy though but
alternatively it's totally possible that
Marvel worked at some of the legal mumbo
jumbo to use the Kree and that's who it
is
it would be a bit left field as we
haven't seen any create anywhere in a
movie yet and introducing them would be
a huge deal and yondu's race we haven't
seen them in any of the guardians of the
galaxy trailers yet either
so why would they introduce him on a
show first before they did in the movie
but let me know what your vote is was
the giant blue Alien a frost giant or
was he someone else remember he was
really just the upper half of a giant
blue alien overall I gave the episode a
solid b-plus even though they showed a
freaking alien the episode had its
lowest ratings all see
we can probably blame the Olympics for
that but the story was great the only
thing that I did not like was the
hospital scene I felt like they were
trying to do a mini episode of ER Grey's
Anatomy and I do not like Hospital shows
if you can't tell bill paxton was great
as a sleazebag SHIELD agent from the
comics and as much as people are down on
the show I think that once they revealed
the truth behind whatever the mystery of
Skye's parentage the clairvoyant and
Coulson's mystery serum are the show is
gonna exist in this meta comic book
place that everyone wants it to be in
like I said next week though Lorelei is
introducing magic into this world now or
the world of shield so to speak I have
some suspicions about the nature of
magic and Thor as Loki practices it one
of the cool things we learned about that
from the dark world was that Frigga his
mother played by Rene Russo was actually
the one who taught him magic it will be
really interesting if Skye turns out to
be part frost giant because it provides
some really cool opportunities to mirror
Loki's narrative finding out you descent
from your sworn enemies but you made
home with a different race of beings
Loki obviously went a little bit nutters
with that but he is named after the god
of mischief here are actually a couple
other big giant comic book bombs that
are being dropped on arrow if you're not
watching it yet because you should be
right now an arrow they're bringing on
the Suicide Squad they totally just
teased Harley Quinn for the next episode
I'll be talking about that later tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get that
video also feel free to leave me any
suggestions for my next Marvel movie
video on Tuesday right now click here
for all my Loki clairvoyant theories
it's still up for grabs so we'll see but
you can also click here to learn all
about my top choices for Captain America
3 thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight
high fives
you